[音楽]
まずこの映像を見てください
me
wh
[音楽]
me
このように子供たちと活動して10年が経過します
着ぐるみは子どもたちの安全確保のためきています
声かけ活動は毎週土曜夕方
名古屋駅西口で行っています
活動しているのは声をかけられて仲間に加わった
中高生や大学生20代前半のボランティア
彼らは一時避難先や週末の楽しみとして参加しています
知らない人に声をかけるというのはとても勇気のいることです
安心してください
ほとんどの場合無視されます
長年やっている僕も心が折れることがあります
それなのに私たちの中で一番人気なのは
声かけ活動なんです
なぜだと思いますか
それは面白いし楽しいからです
ポケットティッシュを渡すみたいな簡単なことから始めます
それでもなかなか受け取ってもらえません
立ち止まってくれたり受け取ってもらえるだけでもうれしい
意気投合したらそのまま八話やハイタッチすることもあります
かわいいねって言ってもらえたんうれしそうに報告してくる子もいます
僕はもともと児童養護施設の職員でした
施設にはたくさんの支援が集まります
例えば企業や個人からの招待行事
学習支援やボランティア
毎日イベントがあります
スポーツ選手有名人からお誘いを受けることもあります
時には大量のお菓子学用品が届きます
衣食住にはコーヒーが付いているのですが
支援がどんどん集まってきます
その都度子どもたちはお礼状を書かなければいけません
中にはおごり出す子もいます
こんなイラマなんでかか中野
善意が子どもたちを困らせていたんです
僕は支援が必要な場所が他にあるんじゃないかと思いました
その時支援が全く届いていない子どもたちと出会います
高校の授業参観に行ったときのことです
当時僕は20代前半
教室に入った瞬間
adam ちゃんはどう
4匹が発生します
これはまずい
学校に迷惑かけたと下を向いていたら
声をかけてくれる生徒がいたんですねしかも笑顔で
救われた気持ちになりました
気にかけてもらえたことがうれしかった
1年後再び授業参観がやってきました
教室には昨年いた生徒たちがほとんどいませんでした
施設に戻ってから知事を聞くと
あいつら改革したよと子供が教えてくれました
家出や買収をしたり詐欺で生計を立てているとのことでした
僕はあの生徒のことが気になりました
レオタ付けたいと考レイリーしそうな場所を探します
繁華街や風俗街
コミュニティサイトなど若者の集まる場所に足を運びました
このようにソーシャルバーカーが積極的に出向くことを
アウトリーチと言います
でも初対面ですぐに終わり事を話したりしませんよね
だから何度も顔を合わせ行動を共にします
仲良くなればいろんなことを話してくれるようになります
例えば
こう止めた
薬を進められた
暴力を受けたなど
終わるとこないんだけどとか
お金かしてくれんとお願いされることもあります
初めは1人で何とかしようと思いましたが結局一人では抱えきれないことに気づき
子どもたちに児童相談所や警察法的な相談窓口を進めます
ところがそれらの行動は全て裏目に出ます
そういうのじゃ
を突き放されてしまうのです
すでに彼らは知っていました
でも8したくなかったんです
彼らは僕に話を聞いてほしかっただけでした
専門の窓口も
解決策も求めていませんでした
僕は声をかけて初めて子どもたちの求めていることに気づいたのです
それ以来僕は直接声をかけてそばにいてくれる
悩んでくれる大人が増えたらどれだけ良い社会なんだろうと思うようになりました
実際に声かけをする中で焼酎不登校の少女と出会いました
中学校は1日も投稿せずに卒業しました
彼女は一緒に活動しているうちに
もっと勉強して仲間の役に立ちたいと考え
高校進学を目指します
彼女は
見事合格しました
ある少女は活動の中で試行錯誤した結果
親と向き合ってみようと考えるようになりました
親に対する感謝の気持ちを言葉にしたり
io を変えたりして
家族関係が良好に転じたと思いました
彼らは特別な支援を受けてはいません
こういう賭けで学んだことを自分で考え行動しているだけです
活動しているメンバーは
早く声をかけてもらいたかったといいます
抱えている問題はいろいろ違いますが共通していたのは自分の選択を尊重してほしいと
いうこと
表3を持って欲しいということ
話しかけてもらえることが自分に興味を持ってもらえていることだと彼らは言います
つまり専門的な知識がなくても声をかけることで解決するんです
子どもたちは声掛けからあなたを選んだよというメッセージを受け取ります
2019年警察庁の調べでは英霊少年は
4228人と報告されています
npo のメンバーで声をかけられるのは1年で800人くらい
あと3400人は声を掛けることができません
一人でも多くの大人に声をかけられるようになってほしい
声をかけるのは緊張するし無視されて傷つくこともあります
でも僕は声かけ活動を始めてから仲間が増えていきました
声をかけることによっ
お互いのことを知り
現実社会を学ぶことができます
そこから新しい目標が生まれたり
問題意識が芽生えたり
新しい人生がスタートします
皆さんもこういう賭けによる学びを広げていきませんか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]